whether he's my real father or not
my mother made a revelation
it's in the back of the book i don't
have to go into it as far as she told
the world that he's my father
and i don't want to get into my family
issue at that point but he's the only
father i know and i loved you had
tremendous influence on me i don't have
the same feeling causing oysters you do
my father don't want this life for me
wanting me to go to school i want them
to be a doctor
i always say this if you would ask me at
that point what i wanted to be in my
life i wanted to play center field for
the new york yankees mickey mantle was
also i was an athlete that's what i
wanted to do
but at what age you're talking about 16
17. yeah i'm talking about well when my
dad went away i was i was 18 years old
okay so at that point 19 years old but
you came into the mafia in your 20s so
that's right that lasted all that period
of time
that you
didn't want to have nothing to do with
it well no allegiance no nothing you
don't even like it
i didn't say i didn't like it jimmy i
didn't say i said i had no aspirations
to be part of the aspirations yeah this
is not what you wanted you had no
aspirations but right at 24 you came in
and you did a serious thing of burning
the sink that's right in a secret
society
and you abide it all you were told when
you took the oath from that point on it
was very serious yeah well okay you were
told
if you asked to kill for the family
would you kill and you said yes i said
yes because you're alive because if you
said no
while you're taking this oh you know
you're not walking in that room
absolutely you can't tell the boss no
i'm not going to do it
you're not getting out of that room
but everybody killed you and they say
who's next bring in absolutely okay but
at that point when that sink was burnt
to my hand i already proved myself
otherwise that wouldn't happen oh i
proved myself shannon
how did you kill someone
you didn't live a rough life did you
even have fights did you do anything you
were in the game you were going to
college when i was in school
and my fault every day was in the
newspaper and i go to school with
90 irishmen and five italians and 90 of
them are calling my dad a mafia guy
and disparaging my family you better
than believe i fought in school i had no
choice because that doesn't give you
qualifications to be a mafioso
you have to do certain things that's
right sammy we know that but you didn't
do those things because your father
asked for a favor
to make you a friend of ours that's not
true that's not true no there was no
favors involved how did you say i no no
no no you asked me a question let me
tell you
two weeks after i see my father
uh
little joey comes and picks me up takes
me to see tom debell at the time of his
acting boss for persico
and he told me straight out he says
michael your father's proposed you for
this life is this what you want so he is
for favor no he proposed me sam
that's a favor he's in prison and he
tells them i want to propose my son
you don't want to call it a favor you
could call it whatever you want call
whatever you want but everybody has to
be proposed of course somebody has a
sponsor when he turns around and says he
calls somebody to prison no i don't
doubt you
i don't doubt that happened yeah i don't
doubt you
so but he asks a guy i want to propose
my son
he's proposing
that proposal that guy goes to the
administration
and says sonny
would like to propose his son
so
the administration says
why
did he kill anybody no
he's going to medical so he's a nice kid
good kid
and why should we make him well because
he's in prison and he probably wants
michael to take care of his affairs and
give him a little strength and power
so they do
a favor
that's what it's called i don't see it
that way whatever
to do it it's not that they went there
and they said michael killed four guys
well sami the bull this little this
[ __ ] is killing people shooting
people breaking people's faces for the
mafia he earned his bones okay let me
ask you this
so when
when junior
proposed his son is that a favor
when when joe columbo proposed his son
anthony was that a favor no they're
divorced
they don't need no favor he's the boss
but divorce is the top he don't need no
families he don't need nobody in the
same situation no it's not yes he's a
boss he turns around he makes anybody
wants to make you but but the point is
because they were his son they proposed
why else would he propose him i want to
propose my son
you don't even know why john gotti
proposed his son his kid don't belong in
the [ __ ] life he admitted in any way
before but for power
for power
the guy john got you we'll keep using
his name john gotti wants power
he proposes his son to become a main
member he's the boss
he didn't propose him everybody would
have said you're getting a reason why
that's that's immaterial
if persico is proposing his son
he must
he's not supposed to be makes
he don't need a proposal okay if he
makes his son yeah okay he makes his son
is it a favor to him and to the family
or is nobody questions he's making his
son sammy the difference here the fact
that his father was an underboss where
underboss cannot propose somebody
no the the thing is he's in prison and
he asks he
wants to propose his son
and he's asking for a favor so the
administration turns around and says
okay thoughts on you okay
what did he do well let me finish him
let me let me finish yeah
so now my father didn't propose my
brother john he didn't propose my
brother karma and he proposed me
he asked me a question can you handle
this i said yes
so now i sit with tom de bella and tom
says your father propose you is this
what you want i said this is what my
father wants he said i didn't ask you
that
i said is this what you want
i said yes
he says okay all right but wait a minute
he said
when and if we tell you
he said from this point on i'll give you
the exact words
because it comes before anything if your
mother is sick and dying and you're at
her bedside and we call you to service
you leave your mother and you come and
serve us this is your life from now on
do you accept that i said yes because if
you're told to do something you do it do
you accept that i said yes he says when
and if we feel you're worthy